nous nous sommes sentis orphelins sans
père mais maintenant notre père revient
et c'est le coupable
douze mois après son départ précipité
evo morales rentrer au pays l'ancien
président a atterri à l'aéroport
argentin de jujuy avant de parcourir
plus de mille kilomètres dans un van
afin d'atteindre la frontière puis de
traverser à pied le pont qui relie la
ville argentine de kiaka à celle de vie
à zone en bolivie un retour d'exil
triomphant pour l'homme politique
il y a un an après une victoire
contestée à l'élection présidentielle
evo morales est poussé à la démission
par l'armée et l'opposition
il part pour le mexique et dénonce un
coup d'état
l'organisation des états américains a
pris une décision politique ni technique
ni juridique
le seul moyen d'arrêter la crise et un
dialogue national et pisani des
organisations internationales peuvent y
participer
je tiens à dire aux nations unies
n'acceptez pas ce genre de coup d'état
cette paix sa classe et des golfs et des
salles le pays connaît alors une période
d'instabilité dans les rues de la paz
des violences éclatent et plusieurs
dizaines de personnes décèdent lors
d'affrontements entre manifestants
rivaux et dans des heurts avec les
forces de l'ordre
après un court séjour à cuba pour des
raisons médicales morales poursuit son
exil en argentine le 18 décembre 2019
le procureur général de bolivie ordonne
un mandat d'arrêt international contre
l'ancien chef d'état accusé par le
gouvernement auto-proclamé de jeanine
agnès d'inciter ses partisans à se
révolter
il fait l'objet d'une enquête pour
sédition et terrorisme
le président déchu rejette ces
accusations auront bon entendement on
s'aimait evo morales est toujours
président donc ce procès avec mandat
d'arrêt est injuste
anticonstitutionnelles et illégales
illégal à distance evo morales mène son
parti le mouvement vers le socialisme en
vue du prochain scrutin présidentiel
nommé directeur de campagne il annonce
le 19 janvier que son ancien ministre de
l'économie dit sarcé sera le candidat de
sa formation politique
parallèlement il dépose sa candidature
pour briguer un siège au sénat
candidature invalidée au motif qu evo
morales ne réside pas en bolivie après
plusieurs reports liés à la pandémie de
kovy 19 luis arce et remporte finalement
la présidentielle le 18 octobre dernier
malgré la victoire du candidat
socialiste dès le premier tour du
scrutin l'opposition continue de
manifester évoque des fraudes
c'est très facile de se rendre compte de
ce qui va ce patient il n'y a pas
d'argent en bolivie luis arce et nous
endetter pour un montant de plus ou
moins de 1000 $ pour sa bolivien c'est
comme ça que nous sommes endettés
habille nos francs il y a eu une fraude
ils ont fait croire aux boliviens que le
mas avait gagné en raison du partage du
vote entre santa cruz est la base c'est
un mensonge
le mas a perdu mais comme ils disposent
de tout l'appareil de la cour électorale
qui le valide
ils veulent le faire croire à la bolivie
et au monde
de retour sur ses terres evo morales ne
risque plus rien vis-à-vis de la justice
celle ci a levé le mandat d'arrêt contre
lui huit jours après la victoire de luis
arce et reste à voir quelle place
occupera désormais l'ancien chef d'état
auprès du nouveau président